ще ми забули з фантастично
[музика]
дача в греблі оспівувалися
збоку і також
ось і зможе захистити нашу техніку та
життя наших військовослужбовців за пляшкою
[музика]
[оплески]
всім привіт пацани ось у нас така ось
виробництво
[музика]
ось така ось пластина
присунув нас газон до навантаження
[музика]
розумієш спеціальну усвідомлюючи тему
чого ще можете
попрактикувати на сервер олло
все ламаю
мама я бачу і
він теж дуже викликати прошивання
можуть
дуже важливо пізнього вечора слова міс
як скеля України
система
ну
кільком витонченіше заду на мою нашу і
національним друзям за на twitch
айнабулак вчіться modecom антиною качиних
moda команді наші війська вам нашим
захисникам
навіть охоронці допомагає друзям
[музика]
прямо за раз приїхав із завалу тульського
допомогу палиць і дубстві за
розсіченого
всю суму завантаження
[музика]
дякую вам літа раму спаду
слава україні клас
[музика]
гуманітарний вантаж до переселенців
з маріуполя
коли зрозуміли що місто я точно так
переселенці тихенько багато словацької
області 1 одразу ж вирішили надати
місце їм хоча б переночувати у того
щоб вони зібралися думками бій або
продаємо далі потрібно вже рухатися
де зупинятися
[музика]
граємо у спокої мага військовим частинам
посту по полях сьогодні портфель з
лікарні
насправді він і для там теж там
ліки
вам перша допомога якої потрібна
нашим бійцям з
[музика]
із підробкою для мене стала шоу посланці
наближають денщика до неї не україни
медики також активно виходить у нашій
реальності вата наших студентів будуть
Участь у софті вони лики на різьблених
vacation
надсилаємо гуманітарну допомогу вашій
флот ціну на передовик нехай нас тут не
booster
вулиця
знижки а я вивчав куди
тут-то курс
ось там продукти зрощування
[музика]
нашим хлопцям з килимки гарячих.